this might be
this is one of my least favorite told
you so's
that i've i've ever had the displeasure
of of doing
the conservatives are always accused of
slippery slope arguments
oh you you don't want to go along with
some radical change in society because
you think that some crazy absurd thing
is going to happen as a consequence of
it down the line that's a slippery slope
fallacy conservatives and every time
every time that we predict some other
degrading development will occur in our
society as a result of some decision
occurring right now
every time we predict the slippery slope
it comes true
we predicted that if you change the
definition of marriage soon enough
you're going to change the definition of
sex in the human person and obviously
the whole definition of the family and
you're going to get transgenderism
obviously that happened
we predict that if you legalize abortion
at any degree you're going to go from
not merely a
tepid defense of of legal abortion but a
full-throated endorsement you're going
to go from safe legal and rare abortion
to abortion on demand without apology
shadow from the rooftops that happened
one thing we predicted was that if you
lift
the traditional social and political
restrictions on
sexual activity and you redefine
marriage and you redefine the whole
family and you say that now sexual
morality just amounts to if it feels
good do it
you're going to have people not just
having sex with
each other whichever consenting adult
you want
not even just having sex with kids
which the grooming thing is on the rise
and no one can deny it
you can have people having sex with
animals that's what we said and everyone
laughed at us and they said oh you're
you're a tin foil hat wearing kooky
crazy alex jones person
daily mail headline today bestiality
brothels are quote spreading through
germany warren's campaigner as abusers
turn to sex with animals as a lifestyle
lifestyle choice
bestiality brothels are spreading
through germany faster than ever thanks
to a law that makes animal porn illegal
but sex with animals legal a livestock
officer has warned
madeleine martin told the frankfurter
runs show
that current laws uh for protecting
animals from predatory zoophiles that
means people who stoop animals
uh
are
are not working because these people are
increasingly defending it as a lifestyle
choice
even people listening to the story right
now they might say oh that's crazy
that's tabloid madness no there's no way
that you could you can't possibly
defend having sex with animals as a
lifestyle choice there's no way to
possibly normalize that these are the
people who all said no one would ever
normalize pedophilia which is occurring
right now they're even trying to change
the word for pedophile to minor
attracted person they're trying to
reduce the penalties for pedophiles
actually our next supreme court justice
did just that when she was
planning policy and when she was sitting
on the bench
they say there's no way you could ever
do it with animals
why
why well the argument is because animals
can't consent sure kids can't consent
and we're now not not only are people
reducing the stigma for having sex with
children or consuming child abuse images
now we're saying that children should be
allowed to lop off their genitals
if if a 16 or 17 year old can't consent
to having sex with a
20 or 21 year old and that's
what the law says i think in most places
that's what the law says
why on earth could a six-year-old
consent to making not just a temporary
sexual choice but a permanent sexual
choice to fundamentally destroy his body
chemistry
and sterilize himself why could that
happen i don't know but the libs are
pushing that the white house is pushing
that
but furthermore
why does consent matter in our
dealings with animals
we eat them
we i don't i don't think the animal can
sense to be eaten does it
we skin them and wear their skin as our
clothing
we do everything we do with animals is
non-can even when you're just
ordinarily sort of shepherding the
animals growing fur and they're growing
growing wool on the sheep and doing all
sorts of things it's not consensual
you're not getting a contract from the
sheep you're not getting a contract from
the cow we send them to slaughter houses
so if we can kill the animals
if we can put them in terrible
conditions if we can wear their skin as
our clothing
why can't german perverts shut up the
animals
that seems less if we're saying that
rape is
a
one of the most grievous crimes but less
grievous perhaps than murder then why
why are we allowed to cut up the animals
and chop them up and eat them and have
them on our
dinner plate but german perverts aren't
allowed to strip them
you can't do it you can't there's no
argument from just consent that is going
to get you there okay and this
unfortunately on the left absolutely but
even on the right you've seen people
distill all morality about all things
not just sex but everything down to
consent well if if adults consenting
adults want to do it that's fine and
it's not the government's role to stop
them from doing it this is why you're
seeing people try to legal liberalize
drug laws this is why you're seeing
people liberalize laws against
mutilations against suicide for goodness
sakes well if people consent it's all
fine it's not it's not there's consent
is an important moral consideration but
there are other moral considerations too
what we're seeing in germany now
do not be surprised when nostradamus
predicted that this sort of thing was
coming
to america right now go to
rockauto.com and write knowles in their
how did you hear about us box
prices are going through the roof
this is because of rampant inflation
among other things every every time you
go to fill up the gasoline in your car
what are you probably paying double what
you were paying a year ago
in some places every the car has been
very expensive for me
so what are you going to do i'm going to
give you two scenarios you can either go
to the brick and mortar auto parts store
and you can drive over there that's what
15 minutes of your time then you got to
stand and wait in line then you got to
get peppered with questions by the guy
behind the counter then he goes behind
the counter he doesn't have the part
that you want he comes back out he
orders it online you gotta drive home
you gotta drive back in about a week and
you gotta pay twice as much that's one
thing you can do if you're a dummy or
you can go to rockauto.com a family
company that has served auto parts
customers online for 20 years same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers no
gimmicks no wake up at 3 a.m to save 15
no reliably low prices super easy to
navigate catalog even i can navigate it
go to rockauto.com see all the parts
available for your car or truck and then
write knowles in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
did you like that clip i'm glad even if
you didn't like that clip subscribe ring
that bell get the notifications also
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts sign up for the
michael knowles show leave a five-star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you